10 arbotoad couture Oh ha are my and
welcome to we snapshot of the
Invercargill city councils its people
and the things we do a place where you
can book spaces find resources we didn't
get free Wi-Fi Paris flesh palace we
provide world-class facilities for
locals and we treat it for all age
groups and tap holster sharks Dart
we look after precious community assets
such as the Civic Theater and Rugby Park
so that we can all enjoy quality
entertainment events down here at the
bluff service center we look after our
whole local community with the necessary
facilities for postal services to the
library thanks vehicle today here at the
help desk where the friendly faces that
greet you at Council when you walk
through the front door or you call us we
can help you with anything from building
consents to paying your rates our
engineering services group ensures that
vital services such as the road to
maintain and assets such as the
skatepark are provided here at the brain
turn water treatment plant we ensure
your tips never run dry and your water
is always safe to drink but the staff
here at Clifton make sure that the
wastewater is cleaned up at the other
end
and we help you live in a warm healthy
home by providing you with free advice
and a home assessment service in Animal
Services it's a role to keep animals and
people safe we components officers make
sure that everyone does Deibert this
allows capsule to make sure that all the
services are maintained I'm go mental
health department is dedicated to ensure
that people can enjoy a safe and healthy
lifestyle through regulations that
affect a variety of areas from noise
control through to food safety to make
sure people put waste in their place we
waste this stuff look after the waste
and recycling services and educate
people on how to recycle race it's
important that we develop policy and
strategy and consult our community on it
that's our job and corporate planning in
hearing communications we make sure you
would keep you informed of all the
things that council does the community
development team works with young people
organizations and individuals we help
them plan their projects develop their
ideas and together we build friendly and
safer communities and information
services we build and maintain councils
IT of the structure so they can provide
you with an effective service what
organization would run smoothie without
the bean counters we accountants keep
the wheels turning whether you're flying
in or out and stuff ensure our terminal
is in top shape to keep our parks up to
a beautiful high standard that's our
role at the nursery to ensure that we
always have high quality plants ready
for supply
visitors flocked to our local park
attractions such as the Avery and we go
above and beyond to make sure they
looked after
good boys Eck our museum has amazing
exhibits and exhibitions and of course
their torrid area
Henry everything's been here the longest
[Music]
hi I'm cat and I'm Vic and we're part of
the Human Resources team here at ICJ as
you all have seen Council has a huge
diversity of roles and some great
opportunities to further develop your
career and make your mark on the
community but the best part about ICC is
our people we'd love to have you join us
into my CC so check out our latest
vacancies and apply online today